retards liés aux qu'ovide celui de la
justice locaux vides qui a perturbé le
cours du procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 un nouveau 4 e vide parmi
les accusés il ya dix jours à une
nouvelle fois empêché le bon déroulé de
ce procès qui doit reprendre aujourd'hui
on va en parler justement avec estelle
farges qui est devant le palais de
justice de paris
[Musique]
bonjour estelle donc les débats doivent
reprendre ce mardi dans ce procès des
attentats
mais oui mais gagner sous réserve qu'il
n'y ait pas de nouveaux cas de
contamination et sous réserve aussi que
l'état de santé de l'un des onze accusés
donc qui présentaient des symptômes du
coït 19 il y a dix jours le permettent
elle si ce procès reprend donc
aujourd'hui cela devrait être avec
l'interrogatoire de mohammad usman ce
pakistanais interpellé dans un foyer de
migrants en autriche un mois après les
attentats et qui selon as les enquêteurs
devaient faire partie du commando avec
ce dernier cas de kovy 19 parmi les
accusés vous vous en doutez le planning
a été légèrement modifiée elle ainsi à
l'interrogatoire de salade et slam
initialement prévue lé 13 et 14 janvier
puis les 20 et 21 janvier est désormais
à programmer pour les 9 et 10 février
prochains
et je vous rappelle aussi que la
situation est sanitaire avait a déjà
perturbé à le cours de ce procès début
janvier puisque salah abdeslam le
principal accusé avait contracté le
qu'ovide 19 en prison fin décembre merci
beaucoup installe pour toutes ces
précisions va suivre donc cette reprise
du procès aujourd'hui à paris